I’m ready.
Amber?
♪♪
Bambi:
If you’re out there and you’re
listening,
♪♪
Bambi:
we’re all so worried about you.
♪♪
(Gunfire)
(Screaming)
♪♪
You did nothing wrong.
Bambi:
We're gonna find a way out of
this.
♪♪
I can’t let her die.
Prince:
I’m not gonna let her die.
♪♪
My name is Amber Chesborough and
I’m being held against my will
in Venezuela.
♪♪
Amber:
You want answers.
She’s his wife, she’s my sister.
Bambi:
We’re desperate for something.
♪♪
You better go down there.
Take care of your sister.
We don’t need money.
This is political stuff, don’t
worry about it.
♪♪
My brother and my husband are in
special forces.
(Guns cocking and gunfire)
♪♪
I know how these decisions are
made.
Prince:
They won’t approve a raid.
♪♪
Prince:
We have to get her out.
♪♪
(Guns cocking)
I guess we should cancel dinner.
♪♪
How many lives are you willing
to trade for your sister?
♪♪
Natalie:
The CIA wants a war
and you’re gonna give it to
them.
(Click)
Al Qaeda Commander:
The truth is democracy is dead
in North America.
We reject your influence.
(Gunfire)
Don’t fantasize of a rescue.
Journalist:
They can’t find this place.
You don’t know my family.
♪♪